bring in our panel harold ford jr former
tennessee congressman co-host of the
five molly hemingway editor-in-chief at
the federalist and former white house
press secretary ari fleischer are you
dealt with
you know a number of these kinds of
events and and shootings
during your time as white house press
secretary we've seen them
increase over the years your thoughts on
this day
and where we go from here
well the immediate most important thing
is is the compassion
and the support that needs to be
extended to the families and to
everybody at the school even those who
didn't lose their children they're
traumatized
and that community is going to come
together and they need the help from
everybody in love from everybody
beyond that
it's such a feeling of hopelessness
isn't it
i don't live very far from newtown
connecticut where that killing took
place and it changed all the elementary
schools in the area where i am from and
you can't even get into elementary
schools up here anymore they're double
doors they're locked and if you walk in
the first door you can't get through the
second door
we're going to have to harden our
elementary schools it's going to take
decades and i'm afraid that is the only
practical thing i can think of
everything else will get lost in the
politics in the blame game
yeah which is said in and of itself
harold your thoughts
you have young children
and
on this day the parents receiving that
news is the thing that everybody
just thinks about and what if it was
if what if it was me
brett thanks um
and ari i agree with you wholeheartedly
my kids were coming in the door from
sports as the story was unfolding as i
was beginning to see it unfold on
television
i can imagine only imagine every parent
my kids are seven and eight
uh any parent with any age child young
child is going to kind of going to hug
even and and and hug and love even
harder and closer this evening
i think ari is right about what we have
to do in schools but one of the things
public
officials have to be law enforcement or
those elected to public office
have to
ponder at this moment is what can be
done differently what could be done as
fast as possible
first we need to get to the bottom of
what happened here in this situation
it's obviously i pray for those families
and i hope these numbers do not go up
the death toll numbers but as bill
malugan and others who in his great
reporting earlier what we
what we learned is that the numbers may
go up and even trace gallagher as he
covered this earlier
schools and streets
subways public places like grocery
stores i think we have to be willing to
confront the conversation around guns
and figure out if there are things
sensible things that we can do of course
it's a hard charge and highly
politicized conversation at times but
one thing we know for certain
and i think that your last guess uh the
police former d.c police detective said
it earlier there are too many guns on
the streets this is not a statement
about the second amendment this is just
a statement that too many too many of
the wrong people have guns in their
hands and hire homeless people and
others getting guns in their hands when
they can't feed themselves
and can't can't support themselves but
somehow another can find the money to
buy a gun
again we we need to get to the bottom of
all this that there's a lot of heartfelt
uh condolences and other other things
that are going out to these families in
this community and i certainly don't
want to interrupt that but those in
public life shouldn't shirk their
responsibilities we need to have these
hard uncomfortable conversations about
what we can do to prevent these kinds of
things from happening going forward
molly
you know i do think at times like this
people sort of take comfort in talking
about political answers
to
what's happening at this school and in
so many other mass shootings and that's
fine i mean
restoring peace and order to our society
it is a political question and it does
need to be debated it's also true that
this is evil and that there are things
beyond politics that we need to do we
just seem to be a completely broken
country that does not love one another
the person who committed this horrible
act is responsible alone for what what
happened
but there are bigger issues in play
about how we treat one another
the love we show whether we value human
life and
this is something political but it's
also something much more than political
and i think everybody should
think about the people in their lives
love one another uh think about how to
show love to people that you maybe don't
normally show love to to address the
brokenness and fallenness and to
you know pray for relief from from this
sin that is besieging us you know
throughout the land this is the second
mass shooting in 10 days and it's
untenable what we have here and it's you
know again politics is an appropriate
response but this is something much
deeper there's a moral rot going on that
we all need to
dig in and try to address
thank you panel stand by if you would
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else